at raf waddington to talk to uh some of
our uh crew the uh the the officers who
are involved in very very important uh
intelligence gathering and surveillance
and some of the uh some of the planes
here today are going to be used very
shortly over the border in uh in in
belarus in poland and elsewhere over uh
ukraine to to see what's going on and to
allow us to have even finer detail
evaluation of
the military dispositions there what is
the latest intelligence you have
regarding the withdrawal of russian
troops from the border with ukraine i
wish i could give everybody better news
about this but i have to tell you that
the picture is
continuing to be very grim and
today as as i'm sure you've already
picked up uh a kindergarten was shelled
in uh what we're taking to be a uh what
we know was a false flag operation
designed to uh
to discredit the ukrainians are designed
to create a a pretext a a spurious
provocation
for russian action we fear very much
that that is the kind of thing we'll see
more of over the next few days and
what we're doing is making sure that we
do everything to strengthen the package
of sanctions that will follow
immediately should there be a russian
invasion we're strengthening the eastern
frontier of of nato and i'll be going to
uh to the european security conference
in munich uh a little bit later on uh
over the weekend to to talk about what
we're gonna do to unify the west are you
having to rush forward your ban on tier
tier one visas these so-called golden
visas because you're worried about a
rush of applications i mean is this a is
this a sign of a crackdown on russian
money in the uk i think it's very
important that we
address all the issues that we can as
fast as as we can and
we have already some very tough laws on
on money laundering on uh people uh
laundering ill-gotten gains here in the
in the uk
but clearly uh it's time to to bring in
some tough sanctions against the the
russian regime against uh big russian uh
companies organizations were of
strategic importance and also making
sure that we we entered it we stop the
raising of funds by russian companies on
london financial markets that's a very
very tough sanction that we'll be uh
we'll be bringing in what we also need
to do and i'll be saying this and i've
said this before we've got to end uh the
dependence of of the west of europeans
in particular on russian hydrocarbons we
can't be blackmailed in this way uh by
vladimir putin we've got to to end that
and i just want to say one thing finally
about about what's happening in in
ukraine i do think it's it's there is
still time
for the the putin regime to step back
there's still time to avoid a
catastrophe a catastrophe uh for russia
a catastrophe for ukraine and for the
world and
that is that
if russia were so mad as to invade i
don't think people should imagine that
this will be a brief uh business this
will be a bloody and protracted conflict
in which i'm afraid that uh there will
be many casualties uh and including many
russian casualties and i i just hope
that people in russia can see that what
it is